[Musique]
t'es sûr que nous sommes bien seul
personne ne regarde personne ne peut
nous entendre non il n'ya que nous
leur approche là
votre confier un secret
c'est sur cet ancien marécage à deux pas
de la demeure du redoutable comte
d'anjou foucault nérin puis de jacques
gourde grand argentier de françois 1er
que s'est installée la scéno ferry de
semblançay dans un site naturel
magnifique durant toute l'année ils sont
quatre à entretenir accessoires et
décors à imaginer trucs et astuces pour
éviter le moindre petit grain de sable
dans un développement régler à la
seconde à un moment précis du scénario
les tables bascule et on retrouve d une
table garnie comme on faisait à cette
époque là et avec un éclairage voilà que
les femmes qui sont autour
mettre en route jean-bernard gunman les
responsables de décor c'est assez vaste
parce que ça représente plusieurs
centaines d'objets le décor bas le décor
on l'a autour de nous mais c'est surtout
le domaine des accessoires alors ça peut
aller du petit gobelet jusqu'au drapeau
en passant par les fusils en passant par
il ya tout un tas de choses qui sont
dans le spectacle et que on doit
consacrer qu'on doit entretenir ou
réparer en fait en fonction de leur
utilisation
jean bernard et comédien aussi est à
cannes avec deux autres bénévoles le
fameux grand père fils conducteurs de la
légende de la source car une source
quand il y en avait eu une ici et au
pied de celle ci un bassin qui a connu
cette année
des aménagements conséquents pour
améliorer toujours et toujours la poésie
et la magie du spectacle
[Musique]
stéphane baron et bricoleur bénévoles
j'ai assisté à une représentation et
j'ai entendu dire qu'ils avaient besoin
de bénévoles pour le bricolage et pas
pour des figures en quoi je crois que je
peux presque un mytho en ce moment je
fais un mi-temps avec avec jean bernard
et quelques-uns on est là quasiment
je pars à trois jours dans la semaine
trois jours pleins dans la semaine on
ait une maintenance à l'année une
surveillance pointu de début juillet à
la mi août pendant les représentations
la scéno ferry de sens de lancer les
années passant est devenu incontournable
avec cette spécificité propre raconter
l'histoire de la tourelle au fil des
siècles